I'm standing in front of a rather large
/ tree and there's a bunch of other
marker trees here and where we are is up
by what's known as the Cleveland Dam and
I'm going to see if I can sort of turn
this around so I can see what I'm
filming here and in the background you
might make out the famous Lions of
Vancouver those in those two mountains
that look like boobs lions and that's
what gave the name for the Lions Gate
Bridge unfortunately it's a little noisy
because they're doing some work here
this dam is also the water supply for
Vancouver and here are some people I was
walking their dog this is about 20
minutes literally from downtown
Vancouver and I'll just walk along here
a little ways and see what we can find
there is a
a little bit better view of the the
Lions and the Cleveland dam the water
here which forms the water supply for
these part of Vancouver up there is
gross mountain you can't quite make it
out but there is a gondola which takes
people up to the top there's also a
thing called the grouse grind which I
have done and where you walk basically
straight up the mountain as fast as you
can I've done it in 46 I think I did
once in 42 minutes my son Mark is done
it in 36 or something
the record is 29 it is a tough slog and
so there you have it and now the reason
I'm up here I will be obvious in the
next little snippet they wonder why I'm
in this neighborhood
by the Keating Dam
and the reason of course is that there
is a dry cleaner here
and which we go to regularly and just so
happens that a couple who run the dry
cleaning job are Korean
well I'm here in North Vancouver and I'm
gonna do some dry cleaning so we're
gonna go and visit my handy-dandy dry
cleaning
whoops pull me on Jay on the Ducati only
200 on the periodic table
son son down two men to doggie
Oh toy website is all kill Q shipped out
90 days typically they say gay so money
parents Andy
Tom Kha dead turn on the sunny of God to
move all yo where are you Jamie sir
Kannada was one multi whole thing
Motul chain to your Monday that's all I
saw oh no oh no oh no the chicken
chicken in bonn Canada saerom glug visit
as surgeon row
hey yo more cou taganga the HOH from on
Jenna
yagi hello Vancouver so chill tone for
Mook
hey Doc hey Doc hey Doc
guava chief mending comes out me down
okay